[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUBJECT: So there's this
great line about music
that says that "Music is proof
that the human race is greater
than it knows."
You know that feeling when you
hear a transcendent symphony
and you get the goosebumps?
And you're moved to tears?
And you experience that kind
of cognitive emotional ecstasy?
It's music's capacity to
communicate the ineffable,
the inexpressible.
It's this urge to language
that human beings have.
And when crude
words don't work, we
have to translate
it into symphony.
And these temporary
ecstasies that we
instrument into existence
need to be recorded.
And our innovations
with recording music
are even more transcendent.
What started as etching grooves
on an LP, patterning the sound,
instantiating it into physical
form so that it could be played
back has evolved now into
a world of binary digital
information, ecstasies
beamed from brain to brain,
for someone's heart
to someone else's.
This is music.
And indeed, that
line is spot on,
proof the human race is
greater than it knows.